in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Mike
and Shelly are here hey guys how are ya
great Dave good I would ask where you're
from but I'm gonna guess and say Kansas
City that's right
Kansas City Royals jerseys on well you
ought to be wearing them proud right now
life is good up there huh yes very cool
welcome to Nashville and you're here to
do your debt-free scream absolutely
awesome how much have you paid off go
ahead a hundred and thirty three thirty
five thousand mm-hmm 135 thousand how
long did that take seven years Wow
awesome and making what range of income
during that time anywhere from like 50
to about 83 great and what do you guys
do for a living I'm a manager for a
contractor for FedEx mm-hmm and I work
for UPS okay least you're least United
on your baseball team oh yeah there you
go in our money and your money good so
what kind of debt was the hundred and
thirty five thousand a little bit of
everything we had home equity we had
credit cards we had student loans
student loans car payments and house of
course you pay off your home - yes sir
oh wow
it's amazing how much of the 135 was
your mortgage eighty eighty three okay
excellent so that's the seven years okay
you're right on track
that's about the norm completely done
Wow how's it feel you're weird I'm good
I'm glad to be weird no house payment
nothing zero
how long have y'all been married I'll be
29 years in two weeks
Wow congratulations Wow thank you
awesome and have you ever been debt-free
while you were married oh no oh no oh no
oh not even gloves okay Wow so for 29
years
yeah but seven years ago something
changed what happened well I lost my job
actually wrote my own pink slip as I was
walking out the door went home of course
she how do you write your hunt you're
head of HR manager I was a man I was
office manager you hired yourself yeah
basically I wrote all the pink slips
until the very last day I wrote my own
Oh send it off to HR and walked out the
door and she freaked out well I heard of
you let me take over
I heard of you and I went to the library
I got your book I read it in two days
and I did skip the 401k part because we
were just trying to tread water um and
not lose our house so all I kept
thinking was we're gonna be with
teenagers with no home no nothing but
the only thing that really kept me going
is my my job I worked part time but I
had health benefits so that was a big
deal for me so um better than that I
guess we could eat yeah hey man I'm in
food lights water Masek show that's what
she said so that's what we did all right
so you went on beans and rice because
you had to yeah just to survive that was
the first step and that's one so you
went and got the book just because
you're scared out of your mind oh yeah
that was it yeah all right
and I'm guessing Mike at some point you
were reemployed yeah I blues for two
weeks and I said you know what I can
work I got to find something so I just
kept looking around friend finally found
a job driving and had to drive 30
minutes one way and back but I thought
this'll work this will do it for now and
she said we're gonna do this and I said
all right tell me what to do so here we
go you just took the Total Money
Makeover book and did it that was it
that's it pretty much it Wow we did see
you live in Kansas City I can for Anna
yeah so that kind of kept us going yeah
that was about probably five or four
years ago five years ago yeah we were
watching you on our console TV seven
years ago when you went off the air
about how to melt down I was like
where'd that guy go the old financial
fox business oh wow devastating but we
found Jacob yeah no more now we have
this thing called the internet and
everybody ouches up there on YouTube and
on our own digital channels so life is
good that's fun
well congratulations you guys so the
desperation drove you to start it but
now you're finished yep well white at
the other end now prosperous how's it
feel good great if something happened
tomorrow I wouldn't have a thing to
worry about hey man I have no no
payments to anybody changes all the
discussions oh yeah yeah changes
everything
that's amazing so what would you tell
people the key to getting out of debt
you paid off 135,000 your house and
everything in seven years you got to be
on the same page got to have a plan I
wrote it down got to communicate and and
work I work a lot of times seven days a
week I'm especially this last year when
we cranked it into overdrive I was like
I had a plan I needed 12 months I our
last thing was our house payment in a
got it done I wanted to knock her out
Mike I'm thinking she's a little
goal-oriented yeah yeah but you know it
didn't it was okay I mean like I said
you can't stay married for 29 years and
not have the same goals and money you
know and you know go along with kids
really didn't like us too much when they
were younger as we were going through
this but they're both living life now
debt-free as well my daughter went to
college
Kash ruled the whole things working on
her master's right now and has no
student debt at all love that yeah so
that's a great success story you changed
your whole family tree exactly that not
just got out of debt that's amazing but
you did nothing for them they roll their
eyes and walked away yeah yeah
absolutely gave him your book and they
gave it their living life teenagers
hating Dave's been going on along goes
all the way back there used to be a
thing called myspace you remember that
there was a myspace page from Tina with
teenagers would go through to hate on
Dave yeah it was a hate Dave community
it was awesome it's great fun fun well
congratulations you guys ain't very
proud of it you are heroes you took
control of your life like you said you
didn't sit around crying whine you took
what you could you got it done you roll
up your sleeves you work work twerk
twerk twerk and you work together and
here you are yo don't even have a house
payment that's so weird
like weird every time hey Mike and
Shelly from Kansas City Kansas debt free
house and everything a hundred and
thirty-five thousand paid off in seven
years making fifty to eighty three count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
awesome man life is good way to go you
two very very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind